okay so being someone who loves spoilers
one thing i've always wondered is do
leaks ruin the hype for a movie or do
they actually enhance it i've kind of
been thinking about this in the wake of
spiderman no way home and personally i
think actually having moments from the
movie spoiled for me has made me more
and more hyped for it because i just
want to know what's going to be in the
rest of the film for me if i just seen
the two trailers and didn't really know
much about the movie i probably don't
think i'd be as excited whereas knowing
what i know i'm just i can't wait to see
if this is actually true and to witness
it all on the big screen so my question
to you is the leaks actually make you
more excited for a film or are you
someone who just wants to stay away from
everything and going completely blind i
think it's a really interesting topic of
conversation especially with how the way
that no way home has been marketed where
we just didn't know anything for so long
and now we've been given lots of tidbits
of information and obviously i'd just
love to hear your thoughts as i think
this is a great talking point so let me
know below and hope to see you on the
next video